[Music]
it's true that you recently I'm sure as
you recently wrote your first screenplay
yeah thank you for asking me about it
I'm so excited about it what's it about
okay well it's about you know when you
grow up Catholic and you're told that
you're gonna go to hell for having
premarital sex yes I know exactly what
you're talking check and check yes yeah
and then how do you go on and have a
normal sex life after that and then you
don't you're ruined
[Laughter]
I wanna hear more about it no you really
don't
no no I but I was kid but but so so
what's the answer
well the answer okay well one thing
that's in my script is that I went to
some funny different kinds of female
empowerment class you're good in real
life in real life
what's a female empowerment class well
I've gotten a few different ones but I
went to one where they they do little
exercises like let's honor your breasts
right so you talk to another woman and
you go I honor your beautiful breasts
they honor me and they honor you and
then the woman has to say it back to you
like you're bodacious tatas honor me and
they honor you it's okay when a wussy
when a guy says that to a woman it's
it's bad yeah it's creepy in a bar when
I go like I honor your breasts and then
you're asked to leave which is unfair so
you do that you you that's part of the
class what we read it was called
extended massive orgasm and it basically
teaches women how to have an orgasm for
like an hour die for now for an hour
yeah on an hour-long orgasm is that good
it sounds like a mythical creature
nothing's ever seen or it's like it's
beyond that
[Music]
my I start getting antsy and start
trying to do stuff yeah maybe impossible
like clean the house you know yeah
[Applause]
okay sorry
so wait okay we're gonna stay on this
topic one time an hour-long orgasm do
you think that's possible for a woman
I'm just asking I'm seven therefore men
- maybe I should get you a copy of the
book no I don't mean to convey that mug
relaxing you know for women it's about
relaxing you know men like tense up but
women are supposed to relax and they can
just have an orgasm for it looking you
can have it longer than an hour
according to this book
according to the book I know but again
is there actual proof as this happen to
anyone
come on someone yeah I feel like yeah
it's true
okay they got pretty quiet in here
[Applause]
okay all right well a lot of people feel
bad now about themselves we have a clip
here from The Hangover Part 3 do we need
to set this up I believe the gang is
coming to see you to ask for your help
they haven't seen you actually since
right they basically think I'm a
prostitute
and then they well a stripper and they
come to visit me and my life is really
different your life has changed
remarkably or let's take a look at this
clip from Hangover Part 3 min Yeah right
so you you're pregnant
please do you guys mind taking your
shoes off cuz I'm kind of a germ freak
for sure Alan what are you doing sorry
[Music]
[Applause]